por qué
[Aplausos]
cuando eran los niños si no vamos con
ustedes
en las trampas en corredores con el
ingenieras y sentir a su madre aquí pero
cinco sacos tuvimos un caso el yo que
todos por un riesgo recuerden qué hacer
con fuertes
cuando yo era niña quería convertirme en
nácar quizá reconocida por sus obras y
después decidí que lo mejor sería
veterinaria los animales
todos nosotros somos la posibilidad
pero si además de la vida media la
oportunidad
soñar que hubiera que hacer voy a región
a la más fina de los que es porque me
dio la oportunidad de pertenecer a una
generación que toda dicha de conocer las
particularidades del siglo pasado pero
que además conoce a algo agresivo hay
muchas las particularidades de los
enredos posibles de siglo
como es tradición el primero de ellos
fue la tecnología lo adoptamos en
práctica alrededor sus efectos nuestra
viento también estamos viendo como
exclusión ado el reporte de la
comunicación el entretenimiento la
familia y administrar muchos años
pero completo
hay un aspecto de la vida que no ha
logrado algo completo este salto a la
transformación
hace unos minutos decíamos cuando éramos
niños queríamos de algo
pero se imaginan la oportunidad
[Música]
el tipo de la vida para las mujeres
durante mucho tiempo ellas podían soñar
en que se van a convertir porque para
ellas
las áreas del hogar los hijos
aquí espacios y actividades estaban
reservados exclusivamente para hubo una
época en la que las mujeres no podían
no había mujeres había duras
pero un día una mujer
fue a los cielos
tampoco poder participar de actividades
o el deporte porque sería que les podía
lastimar sus tranquilidad hasta que
suiza yo con esa creencia entre los
esposos exterior donde el bósforo y el
resultado fue que esto muchas mujeres y
no a mí nos encanta correcto
en una época en la que las mujeres no
podían ser rentadas y podrían tener
acceso a las ciencias y educación
y gracias también al esfuerzo de luchar
sus palistas
pero además que quería cambiar el mundo
creo que debieron haber cambiado ellas
mismas para conseguirlo
creo que todos debemos de cambiar algo
de nosotros mismos para poder lograr
esta verdadera transformación por
ejemplo
[Música]
y decir yo no creo que la palabra más
importante que debemos terminar es esta
empecemos porque nosotros mismos nos
pongamos esta solares de la misma forma
si un hombre decide quedarse en casa de
casa pues para otras cosas hace unos
momentos el joven que cuando sean las
primeras ideas que juego con las
primeras consolas videojuegos que tourre
haciendo la argolla nueve leyes en los
países bicicleta sin celular pero
también soy una mujer que pertenece a la
generación no añadiendo la realidad real
es máximo
tipo de nuestras redes sociales que
conocen las nuevas formas de las
aplicaciones nos permite comunicarnos
transportar voz incluso culpar a
cantidad ninguno de los avances de
sorprender por el cielo que el mundo
está cambiando y que es tiempo de que
nosotros también también con el mundo lo
que me sorprende en 2018 dificultades
para que las mujeres participen en
ciertos espacios y dejó a los hombres
participar en estas áreas
entre 2018 seguimos teniendo estas
diputadas aún así hay mujeres que nos
demuestra que cambian por ejemplo una
puede citar más sabe que yo no sé mostró
en un país con tantas restricciones para
las mujeres que la educación es la
herramienta más importante para cambiar
esa situación
la educación de gente que está
destacando en una realidad imaginable
que estamos participando allá ver que
está destacando por su normalidad para
la política
pero sabe que están rompiendo esos
países también están en una crisis y son
tiempos para curar muchas minas pero
además para evitar a los hombres
la igualdad ella es emma watson también
están cambiando
es una mujer de cabello que cumplió su
sueño
[Música]
mundiales
para poder los tres que más aire su
mujer es estar en casa que tiene una
responsabilidad mayor que la de ser más
feliz en igualdad el punto esencial de
la igualdad es la felicidad si todos
hacemos lo que queremos tenemos una
libertad para decidir qué queremos hacer
o dedicarnos creo que vamos a poder ser
felices
porque estoy hablando este tema cuando
pregunto por qué decidí hablar de este
tema
mi respuesta fue porque actualmente
creemos que en el lugar igualdad y
género ya está todo hecho que ya hay que
hacer el trabajo ya está hecho
desafortunadamente en todos los países
en todos en todos los días en todas las
regiones del punto de todas las culturas
sigue habiendo discriminación y habiendo
dificultades para que las mujeres
participen desde la familia hasta la
actividad de las políticas del deporte
desde los servicios de salud hasta los
servicios educativos incluso en los
entornos tecnológicos creo que después
de tantos años aceptemos que la mujer ya
está bien de la vida
la oportunidad de presentarles la
[Música]
posibilidad de comer
es la persona responsable de que ustedes
y yo tengamos de sí mismo
pero esta fue mi madre mi mujer mi hija
mi hermana entonces termina de
recomendar pero solamente reconsideres
papel dentro de todos todos deberíamos
de alinear sino además papel
y este papel es nuestra casa nuestro
trabajo
basta con poner atención en la calle
para darnos cuenta de que estamos
viviendo una verdadera igualdad
cuando ya era niña soñaba con ser esto
que soy ahora pero ahora mi sueño es
poder tener la oportunidad de decirle a
los sobrinos e hijos nietos que hubo una
época
las mujeres podíamos ser lo que
deseábamos pero esa es una determinada
[Aplausos]